hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of entrepreneur tools
where I share my favorite tools that I
use to run and grow my business today
I'm gonna look at a website that I love
using called Fiverr so I'm going to
quickly find it here and fiber comm is
basically a website that shows what
people will do for you if you give them
five dollars there's a whole bunch of
fun applications as well as a lot of
business applications that you can use
so this is the website it's the home
page here so it's five drill with two
R's comm and you'll see a whole bunch of
different gigs this is what they're
called gigs that people will do for five
bucks so I will say it in posh English
for five dollars will record an awesome
professional voice over view of anything
for five dollars I'll write any message
of my lips and take a high-res photo for
five dollars so just depend on what you
need done there's a whole bunch of
different things that people can can do
for you so I'm going to load up a few
screens here just at random here and
we'll go through a couple of them just
to give you a sense of the different
types of tasks that people will do for
$5.00 so there's simple tasks things
that don't take a lot of time for people
but for you you may not know how to do
it it may cause you a lot of frustration
but for somebody who knows what they're
doing it could be very easy so let's
take a couple of quick examples of
graphic and design a lot of
entrepreneurs may not know a lot about
graphic design so I'll draw on any
object as a cartoon
combination of individual or animals
humans because I need to have a banner
header Facebook Timeline photo Google+
cover a Twitter profile photo for five
bucks so you know worst case is you're
out five bucks if it's somebody who's
not really good and you don't really
like the design they come up with but
that's the worst case scenario is that
you're you're losing five dollars on it
so there's any kind of graphic design
you might want to pop over here again
you're not gonna design an entire
website for you but if it's something
quick knees that you need done might be
worth checking out another category here
writing in translation
so I'll write an original article up to
500 words your website translate Chinese
into English or English into Chinese you
know more translation English in the
Hebrew or a 300 word 100 percent unique
blog article so if you need some writing
done might want to check out
these guys as long you can order more
than once if you need a couple of blog
articles written or a couple of content
written or you know more than 300 words
from Chinese transcribed then you can
order it on going and this goes down on
and on and on and on on as you can see
with the page writing translation so
else we have programming and tech gigs
I'll resolve your WordPress issues
questions for five bucks
another big challenge for a lot of
entremet up blogs they don't really
fully understand how to use WordPress
here's a great way to be able to quickly
get your question answered for five
bucks install your PHP script in your
web server programming algorithm
assignment so again a whole bunch of
different things you can scroll down and
see just depend on the categories all
the categories are here are listed on
the side you can see whatever fits you
know the challenge that you're facing at
the moment and then business gigs so
I'll do any job in Microsoft Excel with
15's experience design a custom
professional version opinion handwritten
signature for five bucks so again it
goes on and on and on so again a great
tool that I like to use how I've used it
personally I've done it for video a lot
so an example there's a gig that I've
used where somebody will transcribe a
video for me for five bucks so I'll
create a video like this and that I want
to put on YouTube but don't want to sit
there and transcribe everything
word-for-word so somebody on Fiverr will
we'll sit down and do that I've had
someone create a intro for me on Fiverr
so we don't quick intro for the video
again for them they're highly skilled it
doesn't take them a lot of time to do it
but for me to sit down and try to figure
it out
it's not worth my time and as an
entrepreneur you want to think about
what is the highest value that you can
bring to your business and not focus on
all the other tasks that you may not be
good at so fiber is a great way to be
outsource a lot of these little tasks
you may be facing with your company so
now the challenge once you've kind of
sorting through when you figured out
what you want to look at challenge is
trying to figure out which ones are good
and which ones aren't so there's a lot
of different ways to be able to sort
these gigs that come up so say I let's
stick to the to this business gigs
category here there's a lot different
ways to sort as you can see from the top
so the first one is by rating
and rating is basically every time
somebody does a gig they sell a gig
somebody there whoever bought it is
asked to leave feedback for them and so
this sorting by rating you'll be able to
guarantee that the people at the top are
the ones who've gotten really good
feedback similar to eBay you know you've
made a purchase and they've left
positive feedback for you so you can see
which ones have done really well and if
you're kind of comparing between to
whoever has a higher rating there's
something worth going for has video was
another one and this basically means
they have a video as part of their sales
page so as you can see here with these
little icons here it says play video so
you can watch them so if this guy is
talking about improving your website
with 10 tips then you can watch his
video and see what he's saying so it
gives you a little bit more of a feeling
of what they're up to and if it's
something you want to work with or not
and then express gigs will be the day
will deliver within 24 hours so which
each gig does a delivery period and
depending on what you need done some
some are longer than others and they
have to deliver within that time period
or you can get your money back so if you
need something really really fast you
might want to sort by Express gigs and
in auto it's just kind of the typical
way that fiber will it's a default way
the fiber will rank okay so let's look
at one for examples look at this website
tips so he will improve your website
with ten tips for five bucks so oh yeah
it's only five bucks so if you're
looking for ways to improve your website
then you don't know worst case scenario
is you're out 5 bucks by hiring this guy
but let's look at this and see why it's
so good so as an example we'll scroll
down he's got a hundred percent get
gradient so this is good so everybody
who's who's bought from him this gig
really like using him that's great
there's options to upgrade as well here
if you want to use more features so he's
a freelance web programmer over five
years experience who look your website
give you ten ways to improve it
graphical changes coding errors hacking
exploits SEO usability to design
conversions and more if possible try to
fix these issues example your layout is
different in browsers or a community
delete your code so then the next thing
you want to look at is you scroll down
and you can see the review so just like
eBay and a lot of other sites their
reviews to see how people you know like
or not so he's had over 1200 people take
him up on this offer and they've all had
positive reviews to say nobody's had
anything negative to say about him in
over 1200 purchases so that's a pretty
good ratio here and you can scroll down
to see what people are saying as they
talk about it
so a great way to be able to filter
through and see if it's something that
you want to be able to hire him for or
not and if you needed to get done within
one day you see the option here to do it
for an extra twenty dollars you get it
within one day otherwise if you scroll
to the top you could see that it'll take
ten days estimated delivery time so
depending on what you need you can go
for the ten days or pay to have it come
in a little bit faster now if you're
scrolling through and you're not seeing
the gig that you want then there's an
option here on the right side to say I'm
looking for someone who will and you can
put in whatever your request is so
example do a 30 voiceover in the in two
days
do logo designs was write a music bio
helps out a Facebook page it's a
specific challenge that you have you
could put it in here go suggest and then
people will say that they're able to do
a few or not so at first search to find
people if they already have some gigs
and if you can't find anything then you
can request your own gig
I always look as much as possible for
someone who is a top rated seller here
so they have this badge on their page
and if we go back to any of the other
pages you'll also see it on some of the
results pages that's fine here it's the
top rated sell their top rated seller
just means if they've been around for a
longer period of time have more reviews
people liked working with them so it
saves you a lot of time of having to go
through and screen as much as for the
other ones who you may not know as much
about and then the last thing is you can
also be a seller so you can use it as an
opportunity to market yourself and
potentially upsell people as well so
there's something really simple that you
could do for five bucks you could you
could sign
up and be a seller create your own gigs
and so do something like this where you
can do a quick something quick for five
bucks again high value add but for you
doesn't take you a lot of time and the
benefit isn't really you know I guess
you can make the five bucks each time
but it's also the ability to upsell
people so you can see for this gig
there's also options to upsell $10 $5 to
$50 so people can pay you more for more
value if you're able to add it in and
then if people really do like what
you're doing they may want to hire you
to do more work for them right so this
is a easy way to for somebody to try you
out so you have to like what they get
and if they want to continue working
with you then they may become a much
higher paying client ongoing so that's
how I use it for business there's also a
lot of fun things that you can do and
sometimes it's worth checking out the
fun and bizarre section here because
there's all sorts of different fun
things you can have people do for you so
you never know what you're gonna find on
here you know will place your message on
the board written by Obama for $5 I've
used it for having Kermit the Frog
saying a happy birthday song to my wife
or I've had local artists here on Fiverr
draw pictures of myself and my wife for
our anniversary we had one of them turn
us into avatars and turn us into
Superman and Supergirl you can have you
know Mickey Mouse call up your child in
which I'm a happy birthday or have
someone in divorce of Sean Connery call
up your friend and wish them a happy
birthday or say whatever message you
want this is a lot of fun things you can
do as well as it's a easy way to waste a
lot of time to just kind of laughing at
what people will do for five bucks so
you want to make sure you're still
spending your time productively but it's
definitely worth checking out again if
there's any kind of simple tasks that
you can get done check out Fiverr
because for five bucks somebody may be
willing to do it for you and you know a
great way to meet new people as well and
hopefully find productive suppliers to
help you grow your business so hopefully
that helps you know check it out for
those of you who are watching video if
you like it and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up
I always appreciate seeing those come in
and I'd love to hear what you have to
think if you've heard of Fiverr if you
had any experience or giving
questions about fiber or any other tools
that use in very business feel free to
leave it in the comments below I always
read those I love seeing them coming and
I always try to answer them when they do
so thank you and we'll see you on the
next episode
you